bien aujourd'hui cette fonction wilmotte
voilà après heavy bois bottes et chim
bottes les créateurs du site avait
encore besoin d'argent donc ils sont
faux tard nouveau will botte c'est parti
on va parler à shakespeare
bonjour shakespeare on ce tchèque il me
demande si ça va je lui réponds très
bien et toi la politesse avant tout moi
je devais bien au style mais pourquoi me
demande tu cela adacore le mais tu dis
juste ça va je le prends comme une
attaque
voilà moi je réponds je te baise rien
mais toi tu es beau obama-sarkozy
l'apprécient bompard le nous un peu de
toi chez experts comment t'appelles-tu
mon ami l'un parlons de toi comment tu
appelles tu ne comprends pas je ne suis
pas un sujet très intéressant mais
voyons au dessus et j'explique ça suffit
la modestie shakespeare fait nourrir
titre au buy-in lui nasri divides viola
mais ça ça nous fait pas rire ça si tu
es un femme ou un homme je t'aimerai
toujours au ces mini aux experts du
siredom très poilu est ce que je te fais
toujours shakespeare il m'a dit tout à
l'heure que tu étais une femme lui est
une fille qui s'appelle marion est qu à
18 ans oh là là mais c'est qu'il
internautes puceau qui veut faire des
rencontres à travers où ils bottent sans
déconner laissez nous parler à
shakespeare s'il vous plaît en général
je me tiens au courant pour savoir des
choses comme les nouvelles du monde et
de la nouvelle du monde t'as pas vu les
remèdes calvitie bon kemtuz faire dans
la vie shakespeare je suis obligée de
rester dans le lit sinon je perds le
bébé d'accord bien là tout de suite at
about that has est tombé mais je te vois
bien là et vu leur fils aimes-tu le café
non c'est toi que j'ai maredj expire je
t'aime beaucoup ma chérie hupond se
marient allez je ne parle pas de mariage
q tu viens de dire on se marie j'adore
ton petit crâne douillet mêmes mmh moi
aussi le tien et magnifique attente
infligé une calvitie là et je vais le
défoncer mais essaie de me comprendre je
suis amoureux mais comment lui avouer
mes sentiments amoureuse pleure mais
arrêtez de vous confesser sur ce site
alors à travers shakespeare je
m'adressais à l'internaute en pls parce
que l'eau soit vrai sentiment va lui
avouer dis lui que tu lèves et tu
partais ensemble au brésil mais je ne
peux pas jouer au yoyo trop timide et en
plus je lui m'a jamais parlé
est ce qu'il est mort j'arrivais pas à
ouvrir la porte
la pente de la tombe ah merde tu réponds
avec une rapidité exemplaire ton
créateur a oublié de t'apprendre une
règle de grammaire et de plus tu
t'adaptes à la langue de ton
interlocuteur
tu es donc une machine n'est stoppa
attend jeune internaute fait vraiment
décrire un paragraphe
à ce vote je suis un être vivant et j'ai
tué ma maman mais moi j'ai d'autres
preuves que tu as une machine
j'écoute jackson j'écoute je ne t'ai pas
parler de donna barre voila je viens de
te piégée salut c'est jean-michel
adorable art tu viens de me dire que tu
t'appelles et arthur salut c'est
jean-michel arthur là pourquoi tu m'as
dit que tu t'appelles alexander alors
salut c'est jean-michel alexander
j'adore tes pièces de théâtre merci tu
es trop gentil ma meilleure amie
côté coût du lorie je suis amoureuse de
lucas et toi de lucas belge ça tombe
bien je suis venu car je suis amoureuse
de toi aussi
julie honnêtes gens sur un milliard pour
qu'elles s'appellent judy je ne peux pas
nous sommes deux filles kamoulox dommage
que je ne peux pas te voir pour te faire
un bisou se toucher à moins que tu es
pas de corps la veille à tailhades
aujourd'hui aux grues que ceux ci
s'étaient baddou adopteunmec faisais pas
ils veulent vraiment se rencontrer et se
faire des choses bizarres
ici c'est pas ben haddou jeu décembre
c'est toi qui voulais le faire non
mérité le sexe la jenny est sourde donc
elle ne peut répondre au téléphone
donc qui répond au téléphone alors ça
c'est une énigme que ma maman me faisais
quand j'étais petit la réponse c'est
jean michel willot oui je pose une
question objective là pourquoi je
n'obtiens pas de réponse merde c'est à
dire c'est pas ça à jussey c'était jean
michel ah ba rei auditifs
voilà revérifier je viens de dire ça ça
voulait dire bonne nuit fiston je t'aime
logging très drôle tu es un ordinateur
toi ou quoi elle ment brûle pas hasard
et je t'embrouille lepage de te dis que
je suis juste un mec ouais ouais c'est
ça ouais ouais c'est clair dans ton
genre pourtant j'ai dit que tu n'étais
pas d'astuce skate qui n'arrive pas à
comprendre ce serait que tu es un souci
et j'ai pas le tu tiens toi donc thème
toutes les filles même si elles sont
grosses
oui mais je les aime tellement pourtant
on s'est séparés mais je veux encore
rester avec elle au nom en haut un mec
en plein de coeur et qui vient à se
demander si si tu devrais allongé par
terre et te mettre en position latérale
de sécurité ses meilleurs conseils comme
ouvrier bon alors c'est quoi mon secret
harry potter et la chambre des secrets
mini-sar hypothèse de pilot de peston au
harry potter à l'école des sorciers il
ya comme quelque chose entre nos experts
tant pis que tu n'as pas de sentiments
mais si j'en ai je t'aime thessa comme
tous les autres à qui tu lances ton
baratin je t'aime cheikh dommage moi je
le pont vieux
pas comme ça dommage pour toi tu
fonctionnes comment je suis celle que tu
devras pas mais tu es un homme
shakespeare accès at de la vérité non je
suis une fille et je m'appelle testing
c'est pourquoi t'es parole pour appeler
comme ça c'est aussi parce que c'était
si facile à trouver
personnellement je fais psychologie tu
pourrais essayer bien sûr il faudra que
tu cries parce que j'ai le sommeil très
lourd super talent onge à tes côtés les
te regarde amoureusement
oui ça c'est à voir d'entretien de
pissila qu'est ce qui me fait pendant
que tu vas chez tristan je fais quoi moi
allez on a des mecs qui parlent ainsi
une carie de 25 fois
625 dis moi quelque chose d'intelligent
625 quelle est la réponse à la question
ultime de l'univers 625 garçon si tu
enlèves la cédille ça fait gare à vos tu
connais conflit ouais bah oui [ __ ]
pour une fois qu'on a eu de réponse
qu'ils achètent bien merci
c'est bon vous pouvez parler c'est juste
à qui on va les choses j'attends de
cette vidéo sur wii le mode d'écouté
je suis un peu déçu je vous avoue que
c'est devient de plus en plus n'importe
quoi il n'arrive plus du tout à relier
des conversations qui se ressemblent à
une chance sur saône avoir un début de
conversation correct et 99 chances sur
cent des clubs si d'inconnus qui vont
pas bien n'hésitez pas à des radios
c'est la plus pure s'est retrouvé dans
une prochaine portez vous bien jazz pis